- Mais quand ça a commencé à
rentrer, il y avait une vague.
- Cette vague est venue de
la mer, omètres d'ici.
Elle a inondé le ruisseau,
puis tout le terrain de
Lucie Lamoureux à Wheatly River,
près de Charlottetown.
- Ça a monté jusqu'à...
les portes de la maison.
- La force de l'eau a fait
éclater deux fenêtres du
sous-sol, qui s'est ensuite
rempli jusqu'au plafond.
LUCIE LAMOUREUX, sinistrée
- Tu sais, les assurances,
ils disent peut-être décembre
ou janvier, ils vont être
capables de nous aider.
Fait que mon mari a dit :
"Absolument pas."
- Son mari y travaille
pendant ses congés
de semaine, mais il y a
encore beaucoup à faire.
- 30 jours plus tard,
c'est encore tout trempe.
- Et c'est la course contre
la montre avant l'arrivée
du temps froid pour isoler à
nouveau le sous-sol et installer
deux nouvelles fenêtres.
- Il n'y a pas assez
de "workers" pour
faire les travaux.
- Il manque de travailleurs,
parce qu'ils sont déjà bien
occupés à réparer les maisons
partout dans l'île.
À CorÀ CorÀ CorÀ Cornwall, une e
espère terminer les travaux
sur celle-ci avant les Fêtes.
"Il faut remplacer
tous les bardeaux du toit",
nous explique Justin Somers,
preneur en construction.
À l'intérieur, il ne reste
que la structure. Il a fallu
arracher le reste; la pluie
a fait beaucoup de dégâts.
Il a une soixantaine de
sinistrés sur sa liste
d'attente.
Il aimerait embaucher
d'autres travailleurs.
Il n'en trouve pas.
Les dommages sont
bien visbien visbien visbien vit
à l'autre de la province.
Des images aériennes de la
région de Rustico montrent
les dommages près des côtes.
Quatre semaines après
le passage de Fiona,
des maisons sont toujours
dans un état lamentable.
Le grand ménage se poursuit
dans la capitale, Charlottetown.
Il y a encore de nombreux
gros arbres à couper.
Et des maisons à libérer,
comme celle de ce couple âgé
qui regarde la scèneavec son pe.
"C'est un soulagement.
On a continué à vivre
dans la maison. On avait hâte
que l'arbre soit enlevé."- C'ese
comment l'eau est venue...
- Lucie peine à croire
ce qui lui arrive.
Ses deux véhicules,
inondés eux aussi,
sont une perte totale.
- On est vraiment fatigués.
Puis, il y a trop qui
dans la tête.
Tu sais, c'est comme...
il y a trop.
- Il faudra encore
beaucoup de patience
pour se remettre de Fiona.
Ici Michèle Brideau,
Radio-Canada, Wheatly River